Rapunzel spent most of her life
believing that the world was a terrible
place but she soon found out that she'd
been lied to by the person she trusted
the most well it looks like Mother
Gothel isn't the only one who lied watch
until the end to find out what
Rapunzel's real mother's been hiding now
let's jump right into the secret history
of Rapunzel from tangled I've been on
this incredible journey and I've seen
and learned so much
why Rapunzel's parents never gave up
hope we all know how a Rapunzel ended up
in her Tower but what we don't
understand is how our parents never gave
up on locating her 18 years is a super
long time to mourn which is why many of
us were confused about the fact that
King Frederick and Queen Ariana
continued to light lanterns on the eve
of their daughter's birthday year after
year
Rapunzel's father knew that the golden
flower held magical properties but that
didn't stop him from seeking it out in
the heat of the moment he thought that
he was saving his wife and future child
not harming them in a way King Frederick
saved his wife's life at the expense of
his daughter's freedom Rapunzel's
parents didn't know about her magical
powers because if they had they probably
would have guarded her crib after their
daughter was kidnapped the king and
queen of corona searched every inch of
their kingdom but were never able to
locate their little girl again so if
they didn't know about her powers and
they couldn't find her anywhere
why keep lighting lanterns for her it
seems like Rapunzel's mom and dad knew a
little more than they let on and that
they were compensating for their guilts
could it be that King Frederick made a
deal with Mother Gothel to save his
wife's life well it could be after all
that's how the original fairy tale goes
Queen Ariana was a crowd pleaser if
there's one thing Disney movies have
taught us it's that no one is innocent
while Rapunzel's parents might appear to
be kind-hearted they've managed to make
our radars go off there's nothing worse
than losing a child but surely Queen
Ariana and her husband knew that they
were taking a risk by using a magical
flower for selfish reasons tinkled is
such an amazing Disney movie that
producer saw fit to create a series
entangled the series we get to
experience Rapunzel's journey firsthand
and
here that we start to notice that things
aren't what they seem to be in the
episode titled the way of the willow
we're introduced to Queen Ariana's
younger sister willow and it's this
character that brings up Ariana's past
in this episode we learned that when
Arianna was just a princess she was
obsessed with pleasing other people so
much so that her eagerness to please and
impress harmed her in the long run so
how does a vain person end up
transforming themselves into a modest
and kind queen
well we couldn't tell you because let's
face it the numbers just don't add up
could it be that Ariana was never sick
at all but that she wanted her and her
daughter to remain young and pleasing
for as long as possible well you guys
can be the judge of that
tonight was supposed to be special the
Queen became infertile magic comes with
a price and unfortunately the price for
life is often death two lives were saved
when the golden flower was used on Queen
Ariana but to compensate Rapunzel's
quality of life suffered a huge blow but
as previously mentioned two lives were
saved which means that something else
had to have been taken away have you
guys ever noticed that King Frederick
and Queen Ariana never had any other
children well we have and we're having a
hard time understanding why they
wouldn't after all someone needs to take
over the crown after they're long gone
right could it be that the magical
golden flower halted Queen Ariana's
reproductive organs because this would
help put things into perspective well we
didn't expect the king and queen of
Perona to have another baby directly
after Rapunzel's disappearance
we found it weird that they spent 18
years waiting for their daughter to come
home instead of expanding their family
so we're left to believe that the
flowers magic prevented the king and
queen from furthering their bloodlines
does this make any sense to you or are
we grasping at straws here and what is
that the truth behind Queen Ariana's
pregnancy nothing in this world is free
which is why many of us get taken for a
ride when we forget to read the final
print both Queen Ariana and King
Frederick learned this firsthand when
their baby girl was stolen from her crib
it's been confirmed that ariana suffered
from a deadly sickness that put her
unborn baby at risk
however Disney also confirmed that
Rapunzel was a fully grown fetus at the
time of her mother's illness since king
frederick wanted to save his wife and
unborn child without risking the other
he sent his men to locate a magical
golden flower while this flower ended up
saving Ariana's life it put Rapunzel's
in eminent danger but evidently King
Frederick never considered the idea that
his unborn baby might be affected by the
flowers magic if he had then perhaps he
would have opted for a c-section and
chosen to leave his wife's life up to
the gods trying to save both his wife
and daughter ended up hurting everyone
in the long run so wouldn't it have been
better to sacrifice a fully grown woman
for a newborn in the end though we
should cut the king some slack after all
choosing between two people is never an
easy decision do you guys think it's
possible that Rapunzel's life was never
in danger in the first place but that
king frederick pretended it was to
prevent himself from having to raise a
child alone King Frederick repeated
Goethals mistake Rapunzel spent the
majority of her life cooped up in her
tower which led her to have severe
anxiety on top of that she was made to
believe that her captor was her mother
which made her realized that just
because someone is taking care of you
doesn't mean that they have your best
intentions at heart in the end got those
actions affected more than Rapunzel's
quality of life it also caused her
parents to maintain a state of paranoia
after finding out who she was
Rapunzel returned to Corona and reunited
with their long-lost family and things
seemed to be perfect for a little while
before long though king frederick lost
sight of his morals and began to treat
Rapunzel the same way Mother Gothel had
entangled before ever after we find out
that King Frederick built a wall between
his kingdom and the rest of the world
turning Rapunzel into a captive once
more
instead of rekindling his relationship
with his daughter he pushed her away by
upping security regulations in the
castle his state of paranoia grew so
intense that he even had guards watching
Rapunzel 24/7
this caused the princess to rebel and
escape her father's reached by going
over the wall in the end King
Frederick's actions
rapunzel to come face to face with her
magical rocks which led her blonde hair
to return once more so in other words
King Frederick was fated to repeat
Goethals mistakes Rapunzel was never
supposed to live we all love Dizzy's
Rapunzel and how could we not she's
everything a person could want in a
future leader No
you were wrong about the world yet
somehow her existence wasn't written in
the stars if magic hadn't played a part
in her development
Rapunzel never would have been born and
we never would have known her
heart-wrenching tale weeks before the
princess was born her mother got hit
with a sudden sickness which put her
life in jeopardy but instead of letting
her go
King Frederick sought out to do the
impossible and accomplished his task but
at what cost from the moment he fed the
magical flower to his wife he cursed his
daughter with power so unique she would
spend the rest of her days running from
people who wanted to use her for selfish
reasons in the episode in like Flynn we
find out that King Frederick used to be
in the military which makes us believe
that he's done some things he can't take
back
could it be that King Frederick did
something so horrible that he was cursed
with losing the ones he loved if so that
would explain how his wife became
terminally ill during her last term of
her pregnancy all in all there's a
reason why misfortune came across the
royal family of Corona we just don't
know if they did anything to deserve it
the King's secret there's usually a
reason why people act the way they do
which is what caused us to turn a
curious eye towards King Frederick in
the first place so imagine our great
surprise when it was confirmed that the
king of Corona had a secret nobody wants
to lose the ones they love which is why
they'll usually do anything to stop this
from happening in Tangled the series
some light was finally cast on a family
secret that would haunt King Frederick
until his dying day while the Kings
obsession with keeping his family safe
is justified keeping his daughter in the
dark isn't King Frederick lies to his
daughter about the black rock she
stumbles across claiming that he had no
idea about their existence however it's
later revealed that he knows more than
he previously led on so what's the
King's big secret well it's that he knew
the magical flower would curse his
kingdom but chose to use it anyways in
his hour of need he opted for the easy
way out and paid the big price
so you see Rapunzel's fate was decided
before she was even born
and by her father no less I have magic
hair that glows when I sing a royal
sacrifice when you really love someone
you do everything you can to make them
happy even if it means jeopardizing your
own happiness
keeping Rapunzel safe was always the
king's number-one priority but he let
his fear stop his love from shining
through
just because someone loves you doesn't
mean that they get to make your
decisions for you and this is especially
true in Rapunzel's case because she was
18 years old by the time she returned
home while her parents can sympathize
with the hardships she faced they don't
understand what she went through because
if they did they would have never
resorted to locking her up in a tower
for her own safe keeping it turns out
that Rapunzel went from being mother
Goethals captive to her father's
prisoner and we don't know which one is
worse tangled the series helps us
understand precisely what king frederick
was going through feeding his wife the
magical flowers caused a flurry of
events to occur which turned a once
loving husband and father into a tyrant
it's clear that King Frederick's actions
caused everyone a lot of pain which is
why we believe that a good old-fashioned
Disney sacrifice is in order do you
think that the removal of King Frederick
would put an end to the madness that's
plagued the royal family since the day
Rapunzel was born Queen Ariana also has
powers we spent so much time focusing on
King Frederick that we nearly forgot
about Queen Ariana while she may appear
to be as innocent as a Rapunzel we have
a theory that might tip the scale if
there's one thing we find a little
strange
it's how Rapunzel ended up with special
powers but her mother didn't so we're
left to believe that Queen Ariana might
have a little secret of her own did you
guys ever notice how the queen of Corona
hasn't seemed to eat a single day since
her daughter was born because we did and
let's face it wrinkles don't lie while
her hair might not shine as brightly as
Rapunzel's does the Queen might have
adopted some of the flowers properties
mother Gothel knew that singing to the
flower would bring her you but there's a
reason why she didn't ingest it as
previously mentioned consuming the
flowers magic comes with a price
but for now
seems like Queen Arianna is racking up
some interests we'd love to see a second
tangled movie that puts the queen and
king of Crona under the scope would you
let us know which theories were your
favorite in the comments below and
that's the end of our video thanks for
watching and see you next time on the
things
[Music]